[موسيقى]
بحافظ على رمضان ان انا بعد الفطار
قبل اما افطر مثلا ممكن انزل اتمشى شويه
ان ده بيساعد على الحرق طبعا بيبقى
الموضوع متعب شويه بس ده بيفرق جدا انا ما
باكلش كتير على الفطار وكده عشان ايه
احافظ وبمشي بعد الفطار ساعه كل يوم بتمشي
شويه وبنزل بعد كده التمرين وبتكون الدنيا
خفيفه بالحركه والواحد بيحاول يقلل الدهون
والزيوت وكده بخلص حاجتي بتاعه الصبح دي
شويه بيبقى في شويه مجهود طبعا الصبح
الاكل طبعا ما باكلش كتير وبشرب ميه كتير
بتمشي كتير بعد الفطار مش اول ما المغرب
بياذن تتباع على طول يعني رايك كفايه
وكوبايه ميه وبعدين نصلي المغرب وبعدين
ايه تبدا تاكل بس ما تتقلش برده في الاكل
وحاول تمشي رجلك كثير ما اقولكش روح الجيم
او روح العب رياضه حاول تمشي نفسك تخدم
الاكل يعني
[موسيقى]